the u.s supreme court has refused to
block a texas law banning abortion after
six weeks of pregnancy the country's
most far-reaching curb on abortions in
half a century the texas law signed by
the republican governor greg abbott in
may prohibits abortions once medical
professionals can detect a fetal
heartbeat usually at about six weeks and
before most women even know that they
are pregnant that and other topics now
with uh political and women's rights
activist dr scholler and also our us
political commentator scotty hello to
you both thank you for joining us on the
programme this morning ladies let's
start with that uh abortion rule because
for a lot of women in the uk it's
unfathomable um scotty your thoughts
well my thoughts is it's not that this
is
reducing roe versus weight as a lot of
pro-abortion advocates have made it just
simply says once a heartbeat is failed
which is what a lot majority of those of
faith believe that that's when that life
begins you cannot murder the baby which
is usually around five to six weeks
there are exceptions within that rule
that includes rape that includes places
where the mother's life is in danger
it's like any other pro-life stance it's
just in this case this is the first
governance of the first state that's
actually put this restriction and like i
said it's five to six weeks by then most
women especially if they have been in an
emergency situation like a rape or a
place um they have kept track of what is
going on and realize that there is
something going on with their body and
can receive the proper medical attention
that i think is this has just been a big
a big ordeal uh made because i think
there's a lot of pro-choice people that
are very much afraid that the roe versus
wade is being reversed and that's not
what this law does
okay
so that's categorically unequivocally
wrong
this this um this
is why you call it a heartbeat bill
what's wrong with that
speaking scotty so this bill is totally
anti-choice it is not pro-life
this bill is just another example of
more fundamental christian extremists
trying to force their views on other
people this bill has zero exceptions
which is why greg abbott said well women
don't worry about it because we're going
to eliminate rape it has no exceptions
for rape and that statement he made
about eliminating rape
by getting rid of every rapist on the
street is so obtuse and speaks to the
rape culture that this republican party
is absolutely promoting so let us be
clear this um this bill it does overturn
roe v wade it is now encouraging other
states in the united states to do the
same other republican states to do the
same this bill is purely about
controlling women's bodies this bill is
purely about blaming women and making
them carry the burden that men have it
doesn't recognize that men have a role
to play here
why is
it's from six weeks the time that you
feel a heartbeat and by then if you are
raped you will know six weeks whether or
not you're pregnant or not you are
paying attention to what is going on and
this is an advocating for the life of
the baby a female baby
is advocating for life get to tell
absolutely false what you're saying
if you wouldn't mind please scotty dr
shella go on
scotty you don't get to tell other women
that they should know what's going on
with their buddies with my first child i
didn't i was pregnant until i was four
months pregnant that doesn't mean i
wasn't paying attention it just means
our bodies react and behave differently
with pregnancies you don't take that
choice away and six weeks is not six
weeks you should know that you know how
the menstrual
cycle works you know for a fact that for
some women it's regular it's irregular
at some point in time it reduces so no
it is not six weeks women have and
should have total control of their
bodies and should determine as and when
they want to have children if you want
to talk about controlling and stopping
um abortions then why don't you focus on
men why don't we mandate that men have
vasectomies which can be reversed why
don't we
complain i'm voting on men
let scotty come in please show that uh
scotty go on
well and this is where i think you see
the both ways i have no problem let's
talk about having male health let's
start having those conversations about
actually putting the priorities but here
is where the hypocrisy in the situation
is because at the same time my body my
choice and yet these same people are the
ones that are actually here in america
saying you don't get any sort of care if
you've not been vaccinated you don't
have a body or a choice when it comes to
vaccines but by golly when it comes to
actually killing a life after their
heart is beating that that's all the
woman's choice who gives that baby the
choice and if you are an emergency
situation like a rape i guarantee you
are watching what is going on with your
body you are making sure yeah guarantee
you're not just going to ignore your own
health concerns for sickness
and this is the you can't guarantee
anything of the sword and this is a kind
of this is the issue when women like you
scotty back these kind of indefensible
bills all you're doing is making it
harder for other women to actually
exercise their own free will you don't
get to tell another woman you should
know what's going on with their body
because their body will tell them and
they will know as and when their
situation arises it should be between
them and their medical practitioner it
is not for you to point fingers at them
it is not for you to say to them well
you should know what to have six weeks
did you know who speaks on behalf of
their life once their heart is beating
who speaks on behalf of them who do not
get to say whether they get delivered or
not ask them i guarantee they live
ladies um don't talk over each other
because we can't hear what both of you
are saying scotty you go
i think that that is the contrary you
have passions on both sides but the fact
is this did not overturn roe versus wade
plus roe vs wade was not a part of the
constitution it was a supreme court
decision just like how the supreme court
decided because this had gone through
the legislative process correctly that
they could not overturn the legislative
bill in texas so once again this is not
something that was a part of an
amendment this is not a part of a law
this is a supreme court decision and the
supreme court upheld what the texas
legislature did because it went through
the process whether you agree with the
outcome or not it followed the rule of
law okay so uh uh doctor
final word for me
this was a republican agenda from the
start and can i just correct here and
tell you again that this does overturn
roe v wade thank you for the concern for
the fetus but once that fetus is a born
child are you feeding that child are you
supporting that child are you supporting
the mother or el or as we've seen with
republicans you're ready and happy for
the mother and child to stew in poverty
and inequality it injustice all kinds of
things but right now it's all about the
fetus and i'm saying that hypocrisy is
just profound you have to leave women
with their right their fundamental right
to decide for themselves should they
wish to birth a child because they would
be the ones take care of that child
okay we are out of time ladies but i
must just let you come back on that
point scotty very quickly please well
it's very selective once again my body
my choice only when it in regards to one
issue not across the board i think
that's where the hypocrisy exists on
this issue once again it's whether you
believe it's a baby when the heart is
beating or if it's just some sort of
fetus like a piece of tissue
too okay
ladies very emotive subject for um both
men and women alike thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
it's always great to see you both thank
you